parlement la parole est à monsieur
philippe armand martin merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
l'agriculture française est au bord de
la rupture
depuis plusieurs mois toutes les
filières agricoles ont connu de graves
crises économiques dans les conséquences
sont lourdes pour nos campagnes
nous ne pouvons pas considérer que ces
différentes crises sont exclusivement
d'ordre conjoncturel fait preuve de
sincérité monsieur le ministre
reconnaissait que l'absence de réformes
structurelles accentue les faiblesses de
nos filières agricoles faut-il parvenir
à un point de non retour pour que vous
agissiez l'agriculture française
dans un contexte de concurrence extrême
est au bord de l'implosion
il n'y a pas besoin de la rédaction d'un
rapport ou de la mise en oeuvre d'une
énième commission pour faire ce constat
aller à la rencontre des agricultrices
des agriculteurs français ils vous le
diront il souffre de charges trop
élevées de normes toujours plus
contraignante
pourtant l'avenir de nombreux
territoires ruraux est largement
dépendant des productions agricoles la
colère qui gronde dans les campagnes
expriment leur ras-le-bol d'une
profession qui ne dispose pas d'autre
perspective que celle de se tuer à la
tâche pour des revenus peu élevés
monsieur le ministre assumer les
responsabilités qui sont les vôtres
le monde agricole ne réclame pas plus de
subventions plus dead et autres plans de
sauvetage ou de relance le monde
agricole attend des réponses rapides et
concrètes aux maux qui sont les siens
l'opposition a dernièrement présenté une
proposition de loi en faveur de la
compétitivité de l'agriculture et de la
filière visant à assurer un meilleur
partage de la valeur ajoutée entre les
producteurs et les distributeurs
faciliter l'investissement alléger les
charges pesant sur les entreprises
agricoles vous avez avec votre majorité
l'assemblée nationale balayé saisi la
parole est un monsieur stéphane le foll
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ce
président est monsieur le député vous
avez évoqué la crise a vidé o play
m'inviter à me déplacer pour me rendre
compte je voudrais vous rappeler
monsieur le député que quand beaucoup
ici lancé ben on est issu du monde rural
les posthume concerne particulièrement
après aussi des études agricoles
j'ai fait d'autres choix mais je connais
bien ce secteur je partage avec vous le
constat est le seul député il ya une
chose sur lequel il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord assumer mes responsabilités je
n'ai aucun problème pour le faire mais
dans la crise que nous vivons
si on prend les crises de l'élevage si
on prend la question des céréales
si vous considérez que l'europe et le
monde tels qu'ils sont aujourd'hui et
les marchés à l'échelle européenne et
mondiale n'ont aucune influence sur ce
qui se passe dans l'agriculture
française
à ce moment là monsieur le député nous
aurons un désaccord et si la
responsabilité est absolument nécessaire
avec le plan de soutien à l'élevage avec
tout ce qu'on doive être et encore faire
pour aider les agriculteurs à passer
cette crise
vous évoquez des réformes structurelles
et la ppn que nous discuterons demain
il ya des choses dans la ppl sur lequel
je suis d'accord a été adoptée à
l'unanimité je le rappelle au sénat des
propositions visant en particulier à
éviter de rendre accessibles les
contrats laitiers
y'aura unanimité et je ferai des
propositions plus forte
juridiquement pour faire en sorte que ce
qui a été discuté au sénat soit accepté
et il ya d'autres propositions sur
lesquelles je les dis nous pouvons tout
à fait de trouver un accord
ensemble face à cette crise donc il n'y
a sur ce point là aucun débat on le
verra demain matin je termine sur un
point ensuite il y avait un coeur dans
la proposition qui est l augmentation de
la tva et la csg pour faire des baisses
de cotisations sociales
la hyène divergences entre
l'augmentation des impôts et l'épaisse
localisation men et c'est un enjeu est
là mais l'envol et âme